in our last video we talked about the
importance and the difficulty of
protecting personally identifiable
information through anonymity in big
data
now anonymity means that individuals
cannot be identified
another important element of privacy
however is confidentiality for what's
called non-public information
in its simplest form confidentiality
means that regardless of whether
individuals can be identified within the
data
their data will not be shared with
people they did not specifically allow
to see it
the first is that in conducting
transactions companies do share limited
amounts of information with third
parties
for example if a person goes to make a
large purchase
it's not uncommon for the vendor to call
the bank and ask whether the person has
enough money in the bank to make that
purchase
they're just checking for what's called
sufficient funds
and all the bank does is tell them yes
or no
and so there's a sharing of a very small
amount of information
but the bank does not pass along the
person's account numbers
their id information doesn't give them
their actual balance
just says whether they have enough to
cover a particular transaction
on the other hand it is also sometimes
the case that information is stolen from
companies
several companies have had their data
stolen including credit card information
addresses and other important personal
information
and in some cases companies have lost
hundreds of millions of dollars in
business because consumers were no
longer confident that their information
would be safe
similarly another limitation to
confidentiality
is that companies sometimes had to give
their information to courts or
government regulators as part of
lawsuits that could have put them out of
business completely if they did not
provide the information
it's a very awkward situation but it
does come up occasionally
the trick with that one is while it is a
legal process it is not something that
the users originally agreed to
and so there is a violation of trust
even if what's happening is technically
a legal process
however these exceptions don't call for
a complete lockdown on data
because the data does provide very
important services but it does call for
more care and attention
for example the national science
foundation and the national institutes
of health have instituted policies that
researchers have to present a plan to
provide access to their data they use in
their studies
additionally there are insurance
companies that now provide insurance for
the cost of data breaches and companies
should consider whether they want to
purchase that kind of insurance
finally companies should very carefully
consider whether they even need to have
the confidential information in the
first place
it's clear that things can go very wrong
when data is supposed to be confidential
but again this doesn't call for a
complete avoidance of data with
non-public information in it
after all that's what makes things like
restaurant and movie recommendations
work so well
and it's certainly important for using
big data to make medical discoveries
some of these benefits are of personal
conveniences and could theoretically be
foregone
but others have life and death
consequences and deserve to be
maintained
for these reasons it's important for
companies to consider how they're going
to deal with non-public information
that way the trust of regular people who
are the consumers and people who benefit
from big data research
the trust can be maintained and big data
can provide its full benefits
you